in eastern china the coastal city
qingdao claims it found no new
coronavirus cases after testing millions
of people
china reported its biggest scare in
months this past week
more than a dozen were infected after
the country went nearly two months
without a locally transmitted domestic
case
globally there have been more than 39
million cases
more than 1.1 million deaths have been
reported
since the pandemic began rameen ascencio
has more
mass throat swabs have returned in china
in just the past
five days the government tested all nine
million residents
of the east coast city of qingdao the
cause this time
12 new cases made public by the
government less than
a week ago linked to qingdao's chest
hospital
now closed until then life in china
had returned to a kind of postcoded new
normal
for 56 days in a row the government
claimed
no cases of symptomatic community spread
while china's many critics say beijing
can't be trusted with telling the truth
many of its citizens appeared to believe
them 637
million chinese citizens crisscrossed
the country during a recent national
holiday
only possible after draconian lockdowns
that saw
some people welded into their homes and
dragged to hospitals
despite the fierce measures rorke jones
a sophomore at the shanghai campus of
new york university
believes china did the right thing
people were so willing to just
quarantine wear masks and follow the
guidelines and i think that's really
something that china has done very well
other countries haven't been doing so
hot while nearly all
chinese follow the government's
guidelines when told to do so
those that don't can face harsh
punishment
what makes nyu shanghai so safe we are
located inside china
which is safe right now nyu shanghai's
vice chancellor jeffrey lehman welcomes
students back to school this fall
he's lived in china for more than a
dozen years
his students safely attend mixed mode
classes
in person and virtually about 800 are
still stuck
outside china when our students leave
campus
they are out into the the
normal life in shanghai which is often
without masks
it's people interacting completely
normally
to try to preserve that normal way of
life china sprung into action
again this week in qingdao testing
millions
proving the country is ready willing and
able to do all it can to stop the
disease
china is keeping most foreigners out and
with it coronavirus too
a kind of new great wall to help protect
the country
in this nation steeped in more than 3
thousand years of history
china's leaders are hoping it'll be
around for at least three
thousand more for cbs this morning
saturday
raimi innocencio the great wall of china